everything it was the editor you know
what Carol hast came to me he has just
basically taken over the Anniston ship
of the magazine even though he had been
responsible for last five or six or
seven issues and he had been reading in
nineteen sixty in the nineteen sixty-two
about my my ad agency and they and the
reason he struck him was because it was
an art director who was the first ad
agency fabricating Louis where there was
an art director in this in the main
enemy instead and the stories were all
about my advertising of cunt you know
every month there was a big story in The
New York Times at least about campaigns
I had done so he was looking at avid art
directors exciting work and something
made him call me to get advice on how to
do covers I had never done a cover in my
life and when he called me I while I saw
a lighting I didn't know I thought he
was trying to get advertising forehead
agency and I was being nice to talk them
because I had been reading the magazine
and was a terrific magazine and he and
he basically said I need advice honey
and I said well how you doing now how'd
he do he comes now he said well you know
five you know four or five of us at it
is shit that was for their three for
three words I Hartnell owner we have a
long discussion about and we try to come
up with the the what topics and the
issue coming up should be the subject of
a color I said yeah and then he said and
then we all want it go away we come back
two or three days later we each of us
have one or two ideas on what the cover
should be and maybe there's five or six
of them that we don't quite know so we
pick them out we cop them up and I said
oh my god group fucking grope and he
said ah I said group grope I said that
is that the way you work with the mayor
and police and and you know and he said
no of course not I said well do
obviously don't have anybody there knows
how did somebody yellow comes to
yesterday how and why don't we do this
so you
go out now basic I wouldn't get a
freelancer so you said well how do you
work I said well you know you gotta get
somebody who understands the culture it
was a kind of another culture who who's
literate who understand who loves
politics who loves their you know who
likes alums the operand loves the
theater music that he and you know and
he's like aunt Ellen 30 joke and he
knows one whether somebody understands
the culture and and I I saw him a couple
of names that made with people might be
able to do it and he said any it was sub
he was southern southern liberal kind of
an oxymoron and he said hey pal can you
do me just one favor I don't know how
you talking about you do me one cover
and he said okay I'll do you one cover
and I said what once it was the next
issue do once the next cover do and he
said next Tuesday but not let me give
you time I said I yeah in the outdoors
for next Tuesday well what's in the
issue in East I don't have it here so
describe it to tell me this get a sense
for each a story so game told me this
this this there's one of the things he
mentioned was a spread with a photo a
short piece on a floyd patterson was a
champion in world and sonny liston who's
a challenger and Floyd was the upcoming
fight was a big favor the big five to
one favor too fast for listening to
Sarah Sarah as it was so the issues are
come out the issue come out a week
before the fight I said okay but I went
away and I did a cover I got a guy who
looked like like like Patterson no
six-foot not to muscly and I showed him
and a call to fight I basically said
everybody was wrong about it he's not
going to win the fight he's going to get
he's gonna get destroyed by listed and I
show Patterson laying flat you know in
the middle of the rain left the dead you
know nobody nobody in the
the his handlers are gone the past is
gone 20,000 people are gone it was a
metaphor for metaphor not only for
sports for boxing you know if you lose
your if you lose you you're dead and but
a metaphor for any walk of life here
when your loser they leave you for that
um anyway and and the coveted and the
hip and when he showed he called me up
and he show my god I never sell cover
like this Nevel my life and I said yeah
right he said but you're calling the
fighting no shit you're crazy you
suppose you wrong I said a 50-50 chance
to write you know in the sunlight you
were genius and if a long tough yo hey
you played the game but I said I'm light
you know I really told him i am
absolutely right and anyway he I found
out many years later he it ran because
he said he would quit if he if the
publisher you took a church that would
in fact when the issue came out the
publisher Arnold Gingrich wrote a
editorial saying you see that cover see
our cover we have nothing to do with it
you know it's absolutely true anyway
what a cover came out when it when the
issue came out the it was a
laughingstock in a sports world and they
were wholly of our lead icterus inland
you know five or six days later
listening to destroy them and they were
geniuses banded the biggest newsstand
sales in a history and found out later
there were guys that it is i met the
only a couple years ago and i said when
i when the cover came out they thought
it was the end of Esquire because they
didn't almost didn't expect the paycheck
anyway there was so deeply in the read
the magazine was and i found out later
that they were really in trouble yo
financially and what happens from the
time I started doing the covers
two for almost ten years is to say the
circulation went from 500,000 the two
million and you know and and and with
coffee after cover you know some
incredibly controversial but you know
anti-war meth the only mask magazine in
America that dead speak out against the
Vietnam War in fact we we we were the
leading we were the leading people in
the media in America against the Vietnam
War and and in the support Muhammad Ali
was I hated the fighter at the time of
f2 became a Muslim and and and refused
to fight in in that terrible war you
know so and and owning it all happened
because of haze because people say boy
took some balls to do those covers Louis
as anything for still recovers it took
him boss to run it you know and in fact
you know what you know I'd sent I'd call
him up and I'd say was I so sending a
cover the one and I can I always chose
my own sucked a topic for what he showed
me sometimes he show he talked about
what was coming up with a magazine and I
and I knew the topic that he was
basically excited about was the 1i I had
to do cuz it was that important but many
times I picked the you know like that
cover i did i told you about for the
first issue with lister whether it was
just the spread they put it at the last
minute you know but but i'd call him up
and I say that I said I covers about the
kept here how old and and I said this
one's gonna really get us in trouble and
it's a year and when I'm in trouble I
meant he would lose not only would if we
get bombed to his bike senators and
congressmen and God knows who and and
and right and people writing in the you
know death threat sometimes you know but
they're losing the advertising clients
because he hadn't they
eskil I had many clients down south feel
as they had did a lot of a you know
menswear and a lot of bills with
ourselves and and and there was a time
of the Jim Crow South I mean it was a
time of real racism going on America
about this always racism in the vehicle
but that was when it was rent a rabbit
and rampant